la valeur où nous parlons madame le
Premier ministre dans la loi française
il est toujours question de fermer 12
réacteurs nucléaires derrière c'est
toute une filière que vous avez des
mobilisé que vous avez démotivé ce qui
explique en grande partie le pas
seulement le covid les difficultés qu'il
y a aujourd'hui à assumer les travaux
d'entretien de maintenance sur le parc
nucléaire français quand on vend
notamment Alstom algi il ne faut pas
s'étonner que derrière il y a des
difficultés d'entretien sur nos
centrales nucléaires la France se trouve
donc condamné à revivre son histoire
puisque c'est le plan Messmer
effectivement qui nous avait en réponse
à la crise pétrolière au premier choc
pétrolier de 1973 qui avait décidé
d'armer la France en matière
d'indépendance énergétique et puisque
nous avons oublié cette promesse puisque
vous avez oublié cette promesse la
France redécouvre les pénuries
d'électricité auxquelles nous avions à
l'époque décidé de répondre je dis nous
puisque c'était les gaulliste qui
dirigeait le pays à cette époque